alors autant je peux être hyper
bienveillante quand je regarde le
travail des autres et quand je conseille
les autres mais quand je regarde mon
travail surtout celui qui date d'il ya
quatre ans comment vous dire
c'est un petit peu violent et salue les
gens derrière l'écran c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique moi encore je
suis ravi de vous retrouver une nouvelle
fois sur cette chaîne aujourd'hui
j'avais envie de vous montrer comment on
peut progresser en assez peu de temps en
vidéo et la meilleure façon de voir
comment on progresse c'est de regarder
ses premières preuves de voir un petit
peu ce que ça donne je suis donc allé
chercher dans mes archives
la toute première prod corpo que j'ai
fait et c'était pour un ami tatoueur
voilà un très bon pote très très bon
tatoueur que je remercie d'ailleurs de
m'avoir donné ma chance un petit peu
d'avoir laissé faire cette vidéo bon
c'était pas une grande réussite cette
vidéo vous allez voir que il dit rien
qui vaille au final rien qui va mais ça
m'a permis de faire mes armes un petit
peu de tester plein de choses et surtout
d' apprendre de mes erreurs parce que
vous allez voir que j'en ai fait un
paquet vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup dans cette vidéo d'air si vous
aussi vous aimez apprendre des choses
sur la vidéo vous pouvez envisager de
cliquer sur le petit bouton s'abonner
qui se situe juste en dessous parce
qu'ici c'est ce dont on parle justement
faire des vidéos s'améliorer en vidéo du
montage du tournage du matos tout ça
voilà donc sans plus attendre on va
aller de suite regardé un petit peu
cette vidéo je vais la commenter en
direct je vais faire des petits aller
retour pour vous montrer un petit peu ce
qui allait pas essayer surtout de
trouver des solutions aussi aux erreurs
que j'ai faites là parce que dire que ça
va pas c'est une chose mais qu'est ce
qu'on aurait pu faire à la place ça
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant alors
pour info à l'époque je tournais avec un
sony à 7,2 première génération
je crois que j'avais jamais entendu
parler de profils d'image je devais
connaître assez approximativement un
petit peu les réglages et et comment
fonctionnait le boitier je pense que je
devais avoir repéré le bouton rec
mais après je pense que c'était à ses
limites je vous en dis pas plus et on va
regarder ça tout de suite à la 5
secondes et je me dis mais pourquoi
pourquoi cette police en fait en plus
max c'est un excellent tatoueur il a un
logo
je sais puisque puisque je l'avais mis
me semble à la fin
pourquoi ne pas prendre une police un
petit peu plus sympa pourquoi j'ai pris
la police par défaut il n'y a rien de
classe
en fait le dessus à la limite ça aurait
même pu être sympa de mettre deux
polices différentes une pour le non une
pour le artistes tatoueurs j'ai pas le
logo un petit coup de fil
t'aurais les fichiers photoshop de ton
logo en fait un mail envoyé un petit
export png boom terminer un même
récupéré sur le site internet à la
limite même si c'est un jpeg en
incrustation ça passe aussi cinq
secondes de vidéo déjà il ya un truc qui
me saoule alors le plein sur la fenêtre
au départ pourquoi pas ça pouvait être
pas mal mais en fait on voit pas grand
chose et si je me souviens bien ce jour
là il pleuvait donc ça aurait pu être
intéressant d'avoir cette vue sur la
fenêtre et éventuellement des gouttes de
pluie sur les vitres mais non là j'ai
juste juste la fenêtre qui n'amène rien
du coup à l'histoire il ya du flux
optique un sujet du vouloir ralentir
mais ça c'est encore pire après je pense
si mes souvenirs sont bons je maîtrisais
pas trop encore les framerate à ce
moment là mais bon continuons alors ici
à cette espèce de petite mise au point
alors vous allez voir que c'était mon
grand derrière à ce moment là et je sais
pas pourquoi mais vraiment pas pourquoi
j'aimais bien que la mise au point se
fasse pendant que je filmais pourquoi tu
vois je ne sais pas je trouvais ça style
et du coup il ya cette petite effet de
pompage pendant que je fais la mise au
point si mes souvenirs sont bons le sony
à cette première génération n'avait pas
d'autofocus continue pendant la vidéo
donc on mettait un focus au départ et
puis si on voulait changer la mise au
point il fallait refaire manuellement en
appuyant un petit peu sur le déclencheur
la mise au point donc
donc effectivement ça donne des trucs
pas fou quoi la suite alors là ça
commence appliqué au niveau de la
balance des blancs c'est à dire que on
est dans une maison de schtroumpfs
alors je sais pas si c'était la balance
des blancs automatique qui déconnait je
pense qu'à l'époque je maîtrisais pas du
tout ce que c'était la balance des
blancs ou alors j'ai réglé une balance
des blancs
un fixe qui était pas bonne je
je sais pas trop mais en tout cas c'est
le pays des schtroumpfs la même on peut
voir la peau la peau la peau c'est un
petit peu cadavérique
alors toujours là toujours le petit 1 la
petite mise au point en cours de route
un ce tour voilà et bien sûr des murs
bleu alors qu'ici on est d'accord qu'ils
sont blancs à la base un des murs bleu
pourquoi pas alors la mise au point
alors là là là il ya un gros souci
j'avais réussi à dégoter à l'époque un
35 mm f/1 4 sony's ice qui était
vraiment super cool qui me permettait de
faire de très très belles photos
d'ailleurs à l'époque j'étais vraiment
scotché par cette optique et c'est là
que j'ai commencé vraiment déjà à aimer
le 35 mm sauf bien sauf que j'avais des
fautes de débutants
ah c'est beau le flou c'est beau le bon
ok on va ouvrir à fond ce qu'est ce que
je savais vraiment déjà ce qui commence
à marcher l'ouverture et le fait qu'ils
avaient plus de flou à f/1 4 et moins de
fonctions si on fermait un petit peu le
diable je sais pas mais en tout cas la
j'aimais bien le flou à tel point que
bahia rien kenneth en fait sur cette
image là la n2 net il ya beaucoup de
flou ac et puis la lap toujours la
petite mise au point le retour focus qui
marchent à moitié né à 23 secondes à ici
y'a de l'idée il ya de l'idée mais
effectivement alors par contre
ouais il ya deux light avec deux
températures totalement différente
donc on est un espèce de décalage de
balance des blancs idéalement là je me
dis ça va en plus ça fait un petit show
froid ça aurait pu donner un effet un
peu sympa aujourd'hui si je devais le
refaire ce serait d'utiliser des lights
qui ont la même température de couleur
dans chaque pièce utilisée mais light ou
alors essayez de match et la light dans
la partie où ou mac cet atout pour avoir
quelque chose d'un peu plus cohérent
mais après ça donne un effet c'est pas
volontaire mais ça donne un effet qui
est plutôt sympa je trouve là pour le
coup est mort et le mouvement de caméra
il est sympa en plus alors ici ce qui
est pas mal pour une fois mise à part la
balance des blancs totalement foiré
et que y'a rien peu focus encore une
fois ça strictement rien de n'être l'âge
je me marre tout seul devant la caméra
c'est pathétique
je sais même pas si j'étais en mode
manuel
peut-être que j'étais sur un mode
semi-automatique j'ai là dessus je
saurais pas dire je peux pas le dire a
posteriori
vraiment je me pose la question de bien
comment j'ai pu aller filmer un truc en
ayant si peu de connaissance de mon
matériel
comme quoi hein c'est faux et là j'ai
quand même gardé le sont en fait de deux
les aiguilles qui dans l'encré et ça
c'est le seul truc de ce plan qui est
plutôt cool en fait l'image ya rien qui
va mais le son est bon
le cadrage est sympa 6 à 6,6 il ya le
film plastique en milieu d'écrans là qui
est nette mais mais bon on s'en fout un
petit peu quoique mais sur ce plan il ya
le la partie sound design qui va bien
alors le petit accéléré ici pourquoi je
ne sais pas voyons cela devrait se
remettre pour voir la voilà on sait pas
bon c'est pas un petit accélérer la la
la balance des blancs venus bien sur ce
plan là en fait le truc c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de chose de flou déjà et puis
et puis le 35 mm pour le coup ici il est
un peu serré on voit des éléments du
décor des éléments du studio de max mais
on ne voit pas non plus grand chose au
final ce plan il n'a pas forcément un
grand grand intérêt et là on va arriver
sur le pire truc à la la la la
là en fait ça montre clairement que en
dehors de pas maîtriser la balance des
blancs je maîtrisais pas du tout les
framerate c'est à dire que j'ai fini
mais sûrement à 25 images par seconde
j'ai voulu ralentir j'ai tiré mon truc
sauf que et bien pour ralentir il faut
plus d'image puisqu'on veut quelque
chose de fluide et il ya la petite
technique du flux optique qui va venir
interpol est en fait créer des images de
toutes pièces entre les images pour en
rajouter parce qu'il en manque en fait
pour avoir quelque chose de fluide c'est
horrible c'est ignoble
c'est ignoble ce plan là est pas vilain
mais encore une fois
qu'est ce qui n' est en fait le le coude
enfin le haut du cou de le pull ça
aurait pu être intéressant avec une
balance des blancs correct d'avoir
peut-être la main net et max flou il ya
un petit effet de zoom que j'ai rajouté
en post prod j'imagine ici parce qu'il
ya ils se quittent effet d'hollywood qui
est très intéressant mais au demeurant
pas non plus fous
ouais ça fout un peu trop ok la poutre
pourquoi la poutre je ne sais pas la
guitare ok parce que maxi les musiciens
et qu'il ya des instruments dans son
studio donc voilà mais la poutre a
toujours le petit à ces dommages là
c'est dommage on la balance des blancs
on donnera pas dessus mais là c'est
dommage parce que il le plan il est
intéressant et il ya ce petit cette mise
au point qui vient se faire la fois que
je viens faire pour une raison
totalement inconnue qui est sympa parce
qu'il ya vraiment le la partie où on
voit max alors peut-être que le focus
aurait été plus intéressant sur le tas
tout avec max flou derrière l'idée du
cadrage est pas mauvaise pour ce qui est
de la colo un jeu j'imagine je me
souviens pas j'ai pas retrouvé le
montage original mais j'imagine très
bien que j'ai dû coller une lutte
voilà et puis puis puis basta un chai
m'étonnerait qu'à cette époque là j'ai
fait autre chose que ça a toujours cette
mise au point mais pourquoi pourquoi
françois pourquoi
le petit le petit café le café
j'étais dans ma période peter mc kinnon
comment connecter le café là et c'était
non ça va pas alors admis que ça aurait
pu être sympa s'il y avait eu max est la
personne qu'il était en patrouille sur
le côté convivial en fait peut-être pour
pour ajouter ça dans l'histoire ça
aurait pu être bien et décors pourquoi
pas les tableaux ouais très serré mais
bon nettoyage des outils alors là oui là
alors là je sais ce que j'ai voulu
fermer mais il fallait pas là j'ai voulu
faire une rampe de vélocité donc déjà je
ne savais pas faire l'erreur de vélocité
à l'époque c'est hyper abrupte et en
plus on voit hyper bien le flux optique
rajouter derrière ce j'ai filmé ça à
vitesse réelle est là ohlala et puis
surtout enfin il ya le passage qui
avancent rapidement vers max et puis sa
part après et pourquoi en fait c'est ça
n'amène rien il aurait fallu peut-être à
la limite faire une rotation autour et
finir sur son visage
j'aurais pu montrer un petit peu le
décor autour et on finissait sur lui et
ça ça pouvait être sympa
là aussi en termes de storytelling
on le voit dessiner après avoir tatoué
donc c'est n'y a pas d'histoire en fait
puisque en gros le gars va dessiner un
tatoué ensuite veulent tatoué ça aurait
pu être sympa de faire quelque chose de
chronologique de commencer par un joli
plan avec le crayon qui avancent sur la
feuille et qui dessine le croquis même
si le croquis est pas fini puis après on
passe au tattoo en termes de
storytelling ça aurait été beaucoup plus
cohérent et puis c'est là aussi qu'on
aurait pu peut-être faire des éléments
de décor qu'on aurait pu ajouter pendant
le moment où il dessine pour situer un
petit peu l'action et à la limite on
découvre son visage qu'à la fin ou
qu'après la petite mise au point là
c'est dommage parce que il ya de la
profondeur ici on a toujours ce bleu en
fait du côté de l'endroit où et à tout
mais le reste est cool il ya des
couleurs à sympa j'avais été pas trop
bête sur ce coup là quand même puisque
je l'avais une fausse mètres en dessous
d'un v lux pour récupérer la lumière là
j'ai quand même réussi je pense ce sans
le vouloir à exploiter correctement
lumière naturelle qu'il y avait ici ce
cas effectivement il y avait quand même
plusieurs lumières artificielles qui
avait pas la même température donc déjà
ça mais un bronx il aurait fallu
installer vraiment des lumières une
installation de lumière exprès pour être
coupés aussi la lumière naturelle pour
pas avoir des trucs qui changent partout
quoi pas évident à gérer le tout quoi là
j'avais le logo pu mettre le logo dès le
départ les sites internet sur des vidéos
je suis pas sûr que ce soit hyper
pertinente parce que papa cliquer dessus
en fait et mémoriser les sites internet
c'est pas évident donc peut-être que
j'aurais juste remis le nom à la fin
éventuellement peut-être une adresse
mais dans tous les cas c'est le genre de
vidéo qui va être publiée sur sur son
site internet ou sur ces réseaux sociaux
donc il ya moyen de mettre un lien
direct sur vers le site d'art dans
l'intitulé ou la description ci c'est
sur youtube donc de manière générale les
adresses internet dans les vidéos ça
sert pas à grand chose c'était
intéressant
je vous laisse me dire dans les
commentaires ce que vous pensez tout ça
enfin l'idée de cette vidéo c'était
surtout de vous montrer que au début on
est tous logés à la même enseigne
on fait tous pleins d'erreurs et que
c'est en faisant ses erreurs qu'on
progresse et surtout en analysant un
petit peu ce qu'on a fait et en ayant du
recul sur nos preuves et c'était
vraiment très rigolo de regarder cette
prod que j'avais par année depuis très
très très très longtemps et de voir à
quel point aujourd'hui je ferais
complètement différemment il qu'en
partant de ça on file du temps en
avançant j'ai fait des prod pour moins
de plus j'ai fait des preuves pour nikon
j'ai fait des prod pour apple donc ne
perdez pas espoir si vos premières prod
ressemble à ça parce qu en travaillant
en regardant ses erreurs en apprenant de
ses erreurs on avance énormément et on
peut aussi pour avancer énormément
mettre le fameux coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo pour vous abonner
si c'est pas déjà fait et me dire dans
les commentaires
ce que vous avez pensé de ce nouveau
format qui était un petit peu rigolo qui
peut plus léger un petit peu plus de
détente
et puis moi les amis je vous dis rester
curieux et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
alors je tourne cette vidéo un petit peu
à l'avance pour une fois parce que au
moment où elle sortira je viendrai tout
juste de finir normalement la
réalisation d'un clip assez balèze gros
challenge mais ça on en parlera à
j'espère ce que j'ai pas encore tourné
les images donc je suis pas devin mais
j'espère vous faire une vidéo à ce sujet
là bas du cou la semaine prochaine
croiser les doigts par l'amont mois du
futur j'espère que tu as réussi la vidéo